il est en france cent mille enfants
comme celle-ci séparés de leurs parents
trimbalé depuis toujours de foyer en
foyer depuis des décennies la société
est censé protéger ces enfants orphelins
ou dont la garde a été retirée aux
parents dans les années 50 certains sont
placés dans des maisons sorte de foyer
d'accueil ces enfants sont aujourd'hui
sauvé ou sur le point de l'air dans
cette maison ils vont en classe comme
d'autres enfants il y en a des centaines
de milliers qui sont en danger comment
les sauver tous et bien l'autre solution
est le placement dans des familles
d'accueil jusque dans les années 70
l'assistance publique a placé des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants dans le
morvan véritable terre d'accueil où
parfois il servait de main d'oeuvre aux
familles d'agriculteurs sur quelqu'un 43
y ait une maison sur deux environ abric
l'un de ses enfants pourquoi vous avez à
faire plier des enfants de l'assistance
visite pour des migraines
parce qu'à ce moment
les traîner dans les toiles de les
garder comme domestiques des domestiques
ailleurs heureusement des villages
entiers se sont illustrés dans l'accueil
de ces enfants comme bouillon dans
l'arrière pays niçois là bas est né un
village enfants ou des fratries entières
ont été recueillis par des parents de
substitution et ceux déjà en 1961 le
principe de base de ces villages est
double d'une part donner à ces enfants
une mère
d'autre part réunir les enfants d'une
même famille sous un même toit et il
n'est que de regarder ces images pour se
convaincre qu'ils y trouvent la chaleur
d'une famille et y mène une vie heureuse
une vie heureuse c'est tout l'enjeu
alors dans les années 70 l'accueil de
ces enfants se professionnalise pour
mieux les protéger famille d'accueil
c'est un métier les familles d'accueil
bénéficient d'un statut d'un salaire et
subvenir aux besoins de ses enfants cela
dit malgré le nombre important de
candidatures à l'accueil beaucoup
d'enfants restent à placer
principalement en milieu urbain où le
personnel d'encadrement est insuffisant
professionnaliser contrôler les familles
d'accueil et puis éviter de séparer les
fratries en 1996 des écoliers de cm2
souffle l'idée aux députés ces
législateurs juniors ont proposé lors du
parlement des enfants en juin dernier
d'interdire la séparation des frères et
soeurs en cas de mesures de placement le
projet de loi est adopté on sépare plus
les fratries et puis on travaille de
plus en plus à conserver les liens entre
parents et enfants lors de leur
placement en foyer l'or et ses soeurs
n'ont pas été séparés les enfants
resteront trois ans au foyer en moyenne
avant de repartir si possible dans leur
famille mais la prise en charge de ces
enfants peut encore être amélioré en
france chaque année ils sont environ
cent cinquante mille à faire l'objet
d'une mesure de placement
[Musique]